I've got 27 BRAND NEW Things You Missed from
IT that you haven't seen in any of the other
videos, so stick around to the end of this
one, where I'll reveal those.
In the opening scene in Bill's room, you can
see a pad and pencils on his bed, a nod to
the fact that Bill grows up to become a writer
in the book.
If you look closer at the post where Patrick
Hockstetter's missing poster is displayed,
you'll notice that it's absolutely covered
in staples.
Maybe not all of those staples are from missing
posters for children, but the number of staples
on that thing is pretty high, and at the end
of the movie we see a similar number of dead
kids floating in Pennywise's lair.
So the staples really show us how many missing
children have just been given up on by the
adults of Derry.
What allows this to happen is described as
kind of a trance over all of the adults in
Derry.
Most of them seem to be in denial that there
really is a major problem with child abductions.
Ben, as a newcomer to the town, noticed this
in his research.
"Derry's not like any town I've ever been
in before.
People die or disappear six times the national
average.
And that's just grown-ups.
Kids are worse.
WAY, way worse."
In another one of my videos, I discuss Belch's
T-shirt, and how it highlights the divide
between the child and adult perceptions of
what's going on in Derry.
Roll the clip.
"Belch is wearing an Anthrax shirt, which
is interesting because in the book, which
is set in the 50s rather than the 80s, one
of the few things that all the kids seems
to agree on, Lucky 7 and Bowers gang alike,
is their love for Rock & Roll, a love that
is not shared with seemingly any of the adults
in Derry.
That becomes kind a motif, a symbolic representation
of Pennywise's reign of terror in Derry.
Adults are in denial and kind of turn a blind
eye to the reality of the situation because
they're afraid of change, whether it be the
rise of Rock & Roll in the 50s, or the rise
of an evil being in their town.
With this being set in the 80s, maybe metal
serves that purpose now."
Belch also has an interesting shirt choice
during the rock fight.
“Belch wears a T-shirt repping a demo CD
that Metallica put out in the 80s called Metal
Up Your Ass.
The graphic features a hand holding a sword
coming out of the toilet.
Perfect choice for a movie about a dangerous
clown creature who also comes out of the sewers.”
That's not the only T-shirt in the movie that
seemed to be more than just a random choice
though.
There are a ctually many, many more.
Starting with Eddie.
He can be seen wearing this killer car shirt,
which is a reference to Stephen King's novel,
Christine about a vehicle that becomes possessed
and tries to kill its owner.
Bill wears a Tracker Bros. T-shirt when they
go to investigate the sewers.
The Tracker Bros Shipping Company is a family
owned trucking service from the book.
They don't come up in the movie, so this is
just a cool little easter egg.
T-shirts were not the only thing in the art
department that have significance.
Let's roll that next clip.
"Bill has some posters in his room, and I
was able to identify a couple of them as Gremlins
and Beetlejuice.
Why is this significant?
Well, I think these posters both have double
meanings behind them.
The first is a foreshadowing of Bill's future.
You'll find that after facing their fears
in the movie, that none of the 'losers' are
losers anymore.
They all go on to have very successful careers.
Perhaps the most successful of them though,
is Bill Denborough.
Who grows up to be a horror writer.
Like me.
But without the stupid goatee.
But it's cool to see that Bill does have an
interest in horror as a kid, and that leads
into his occupation as an adult.
On a side note, pretty much every Stephen
King novel has a protagonist who's a writer,
a method he uses to project himself into his
work.
Muschietti and his art department could have
chosen any two horror movie posters to hang
on Bill's wall though, so why did they choose
these?"
I mean... outside the fact that they are both
Warner Bros movies and they would never market
for a competitor?
Go on, me from a month ago.
"Bill's still a kid, and these are both more
kid-friendly horror movies that came out in
the 1980s.
But I think there's a reason that these were
chosen as opposed to say...
Ghostbusters.
Let's look at Gremlins.
It's a movie about these little things that
change into other, more scary things, and
in this movie, IT's shapeshifting abilities
are on full display, one of which being the
transformation that IT does with it's teeth
when feeding off the fear of the children.
It seemed like it took some big inspiration
from Barbara's transformation in Beetlejuice.
How the face kind of peels back to reveal
these rows and rows of razor sharp teeth.
Especially that scene where Pennywise is about
to feed on Stan.
I was getting major vibes from the Tim Burton
classic."
It seems that there was also some inspiration
from more traditional circus clowns like Georgie’s
wallpaper and the overall decor in his room,
from stuffed animals to little dolls on the
nightstand.
One of my favorite parts about the movie is
how there is always something looming in the
dark, so in this next clip, I'll talk about
what lies beyond the light.
"The whole basement scene is pretty dark in
this shot, so let's turn up the lights.
In the corner, there are some oars, and there's
also a life vest on the wall.
I wonder if these choices have anything to
do with the fact that Georgie dies while playing
with the paper boat."
Note: this does make sense, because this is
right before Pennywise uses Georgie's image
to try to trick Bill.
"OK, this is creepy.
First thing I noticed in Pennywise sinking
into the well.
If Ringu didn't make wells creepy enough for
you, it looks like the clown's got you covered.
Scattered on the floor are children's clothes
and toys.
This looks like of like an elephant, another
circus animal.
There's also a noose hanging from the rafter.
This room is full of various clowns and has
a few things that I loved.
I'll turn up the lights again to make it easier
for you to see.
This little guy right here is a nice throwback
to the Tim Curry Pennywise design from the
1990 TV mini-series."
This clown's head turns to follow Richie as
he walks.
It's good to see something subtle like that
and know that it's not all just jump scares.
When they align the map of Derry with the
sewer system map, we discover that the sewer
lines run through the 29 Neibolt House and
the kids make a plan to go confront Pennywise
there.
If you look at some of the other locations
on that map, you'll also see the cemetery,
which means we will probably see Bill's confrontation
with Pennywise in the sequel, where Pennywise
is digging graves for each of the Lucky 7.
The references are far from being over there
though.
“During the beginning of the film you may
have heard Bill uttering the following phrase:
‘he thrusts his fists against the posts
and still insists he sees the ghosts.’
It comes back at the end of the film I believe.
What this is is a coping mechanism to help
Bill with his stutter and it’s something
that helps him overcome Pennywise in the book
because his stutter is directly linked to
his fear of IT.
It’s not that bad at first but it gets worse
when Georgie is killed and when his fear of
IT increases, the stutter gets worse.
Remember when he has the courage to go into
the 29 Neibolt house after they discover that
it’s connected to the old wellhouse and
it’s connected to the sewer?
He gives his friends a speech and Richie even
comments on him having not stuttered through
any of it.
That’s his courage that allows him to stand
up like that.
So when you hear him say the phrase ‘he
thrusts his fists against the posts and still
insists he sees the ghosts,’ without stuttering,
you know that he has grown in the face of
fear in order to do so, and that’s what
weakens IT.
I would expect to hear more of that phrase
when his childhood stutter comes back in Chapter
2.
There were a lot of little nods to events
and characters in the book that were touched
on in the movie but didn’t need to be fully
expanded.
Some of these things had their own chapter
in the book, but I think the film did a nice
job of only including what was necessary as
not to overwhelm the viewer.
Here are a few of those references.
Ben researches the ironworks explosion, a
catastrophe caused by IT in the early 1900s.
He also looks up the Black Spot fire, which
was a nightclub in Derry during the early
1930s that was a hangout for a lot of African-American
men at the time.
It was burned down by a racist faction with
only a few survivors, one of which being Mike
Hanlon’s dad, who passes the story onto
his son.
The relevancy of that in this movie is debatable,
because Mike’s parents actually do die in
a fire prior to the events of 1989.”
(Inside missing poster) Throughout the entire
movie, the town is covered in missing posters
for the abducted children.
Many of these are references to characters
in the book whom we never meet in the movie,
at least not when they are alive.
Betty Ripson and
Edward Corcoran are a couple of examples.
I found a lot of elements from the book that
were in the movie but not really explained.
Check this out.
“At one point Pennywise encounters Richie
and uses the line Beep-Beep Richie, which
is a phrase the Lucky 7 always uses in the
book whenever Richie doesn’t shut up.
It doesn’t come up a whole lot in the movie,
but Richie does still run his mouth a lot.
The reason I wanted to bring it up, was that
I think it kind of takes on a new meaning
here with how much of a pottymouth Richie
is in this movie.
The beep-beep could represent the redacted
expletives.
One other note on Richie.
At the school when Richie walks by the gang
of bullies, Patrick Hockstetter (the one who
goes after them with a makeshift flamethrower,
gives him this creepy smile and licks his
lips.
One thing this movie was very good at is telling
a lot of backstory visually.
Patrick is one messed up kid who gets off
on hurting other and has weird violent-homosexual
tendencies.
At one point in the book he actually molests
Henry Bowers, lwhich is why I think he’s
actually the scariest human character.
He doesn’t get that far in the movie, but
that little lick of the lips at a boy who
is substantially younger than him tells us
that something is not right about his character.
There were a couple of things that were different
from the book, but I think actually added
to some of the character arcs in the movie.
For example, while Stan is Jewish in both
the novel and motion picture, his religion
plays a much bigger part now.
Stan is studying for his bar-mitzvah, and
his father is the rabbi of the temple.
But we’re given the idea that Stan isn’t
really a big believer because he hasn’t
been studying his Torah portion.
In fact, the blessing that he’s having trouble
with is actually just the prayer you have
to recite before opening the Torah, so it’s
like the easiest one because it always comes
up, but he can’t even get through that.
The reason I think this is kind of a brilliant
change from the book, is that the whole basis
of Stan’s character is that he’s the last
one to truly believe in IT.
He even says that the things that they’re
all seeing aren’t real… until the Neibolt
House encounter, and it hits him the hardest
it.
Once he believes in IT, he’s probably the
most scared of IT, and right after that happens
we’re led into the montage of the middle
of that summer, where he actually has his
bar-mitzvah.
His belief in IT mirrors his faith in his
religion.”
There were even a couple of Things You Missed
that added a touch of metacinema.
In the projector scene, there are a couple
of inserts of slides being put into the projector.
One says Made in Canada, and one says Made
in USA.
Filming locations for this movie swapped back
and forth between these two countries, with
much of Derry taking place in the Canadian
city Port Hope, Ontario.
One thing that might have gone over your head
is the significance behind the release date:
September 8, 2016.
I discussed this in detail in a previous video.
Roll it: "What's more interesting to me is
WHY the filmmakers have chose the 80s for
this film.
Many of you confirmed my suspicion that the
book will be split into two movies, meaning
that the second movie will take place in 2016;
the same year that Part 1 was in production.
When you consider the fact that the first
movie is technically a flashback, that kind
of makes this whole reboot series a modern
day remake of IT, an interesting choice when
you consider the significance of creepy clowns
in our culture today such as the Staten Island
Clown and his many copycats over the last
few years.
We'll see if that plays into the second film
at all.
I'll never forget that scene in the adult
portion of the miniseries where Ben notices
Pennywise on the side of the road, something
that seemed to happen quite a lot in America
in October 2016.
This is our next item.
The film is scheduled to release September
8th, 2017.
You might be wondering, 'CZ, how did you miss
this?
It says it right there.'
Well it's not the release date I missed, but
rather, the significance behind it.
In the story, IT returns to the town every
27 years to terrorize Derry.
Commenter CynicalCatLady points out, 'The
first screen adaptation of IT was first aired
in 1990, and 27 years later the infamous dancing
clown is re-emerging to breath fresh terror
into a new generation, just as he does in
the novel.'”
If you haven’t read the book, be warned.
We’re going into spoiler territory.
Welcome to spoiler territory.
In the scene where Georgie is playing with
the boat, you'll notice tents bolstered with
sandbags all around street covering up the
sewage caps to prevent the sewer access areas
from being flooded.
This plant the seed early that Derry is set
up in a way that might be prone to flooding,
so don't be surprised if there is a massive
flood at the end of IT: Chapter 2.
There are a number of subtle references to
astronomy throughout the movie, which foreshadow
the possible inclusion of the Macroverse in
the sequel.
The macroverse is a dark void that surrounds
our own universe.
It is the place from which IT and the natural
enemy of IT, known as The Turtle, originate
from.
The only way they are able to defeat IT in
the book involves a ceremony known as the
Ritual of Chud, where... and stay with me
here...
Bill's consciousness transcends his actual
body and our universe and has a psychic showdown
with it in the Macroverse where he is given
the power to defeat IT by The Turtle.
So because of these deep ties to Macroverse,
we see countless astronomical references scattered
throughout Derry.
Bill has a solar system model above his desk,
a rocket ship on his desk,
and a globe next to his desk, signifying that
he could be the one to travel to the macroverse,
which we'll likely see in chapter 2.
When they are in Bill's garage, Ben has a
T-shirt with many solar systems on it.
The Derry library shows another globe, representing
earth, looking very insignificant
across from a poster that represents the scale
of the greater universe; it says reach for
the stars, read a book.
---In addition to the broader space references,
there are also some references to The Turtle
itself.
Check out the clip where I talk about that:
“The other thing I noticed was the lego
turtle that Bill finds in his brother’s
old room, which was one of the few references
to a celestial being known as The Turtle,
who is an opposing force against IT.
The turtle is kind of slyly written into the
book.
Characters will find themselves thinking about
The Turtle without really knowing why.
In the movie, one of the characters brings
up the fact that they think they see a Turtle
in the swimming scene,
and I’m not entirely sure, because again,
I can’t pause yet, but I’m pretty sure
I saw a turtle sticker on one of Beverly’s
books.
These references are nothing more than Easter
Eggs though, because the primary scene in
which The Turtle gives advice to Bill known
as The Ritual of Chud, is not a scene in this
movie.”
I wouldn’t rule it out for the sequel though.
“The Turtle’s rival, who the kids refer
to as IT, but whose true form is known as
The Deadlights does make a brief appearance
when Pennywise tries to eat Beverly and it’s
face peels back, she looks down it’s throat
and sees three bright lights.
This is somewhat different than the form we’re
used to seeing The Deadlights in.
They appear to be more of a force within Pennywise,
as opposed to their own powerful entity.
Nobody in the movie ever uses the word ‘Deadlights’
so they make their way onto the silver screen
in a much more subtle way.
This next one I didn’t notice until the
last scene of the movie.
In a previous Things You Missed, I pointed
out that Beverly wears a key around her neck,
and speculated what it might be for.
Many, and I mean a lot, like 666 billion of
you pointed out that the key is uncut, so
it couldn’t actually be used for unlocking
anything.
After seeing the movie, I still have no idea
what the significance of the key is, but I
noticed another piece of Jewelry that Bev
has.
It’s a ring with an anchor on it.
What do anchors do?
They sink.
And after countless cases of ‘you’ll float
too’, ‘you’ll float too’, ‘YOU’LL
FLOAT TOO’, the group eventually finds that
Beverly floats as well, after being abducted
by Pennywise.
But because of the love and dedication of
her friends, they’re able to find her and
pull her back down out of harm’s way.
In a world where all of the victims float,
she’s the one who sinks, she’s the anchor.
In that final scene, after the promise, Bev
tells what she remembers from when she was
afloat and says she had a vision of them from
when they are all much older in their 30s
this is a foreshadowing of the sequel, when
after a 27 year rest, Pennywise re-emerges
and the losers are called back to Derry to
fulfill their promise and vanquish IT.”
There was also a Stephen King movie called
The Dark Tower that came out earlier in the
year, and many of you speculated that there
might be some kind of Stephen King cinematic
universe in the works, despite the fact that
the movies are made by different studios.
After seeing both movies, that doesn't appear
to be the case, but it's still hard not to
notice some references to Stephen King lore
throughout the film.
And before I roll this clip, I'd like to mention
that this whole idea was brought about by
THIS teaser for The Dark Tower, featuring
The Shining, IT, Carrie, The Shawshank Redemption,
Christine and The Stand.
Let's roll it.
"Smith Coronna is a typewriter company.
The typewriter is a very important prop in
The Shining.
I already mentioned the Christine shirt, and
there's this newspaper headline that says
'NO INDICTMENT YET ON GILLESPIE.' and I wasn't
able to read anything past that, but Gillespie
is a character in Salem's Lot, in fact, he's
a cop.
By the way, did this shot kind of remind anyone
of Salem's Lot?"
After seeing The Dark Tower, I think it's
also worth noting that when Roland describes
The Macroverse to Jake while they are camping
out at the abandoned Pennywise amusement park,
he draws a circle in the sand to represent
their universe, and talks about how higher
beings can travel from the outer Macroverse
into their universe, and to represent this,
a tarantula crawls across the sand on his
diagram, which of course reminded me of the
final form ["This isn't even my final form!"]
of IT, or at least the final form shown in
the book which is a giant spider.
So that covers all of the Things You Missed
from past videos that are still relevant now
that the movie has been released, and it's
a great spot to transition into the new Things
You Missed that have never been mentioned
before, the first of which being an allusion
to the spider that I just brought up.
During the final battle with Pennywise, when
he's going all ditto on the losers, one of
the forms he takes looks like an arachnid,
at first I thought it looked more like a praying
mantis than anything, and I'll stand by that,
but some of you said it reminded you of the
spider, and after seeing the mini-series again,
where they banquish Pennywise as kids and
IT's arm turns into a spider for just a second
before retreating deeper into the sewers,
I can kind of see the resemblance.
When Georgie goes into the basement to get
the wax, they have a clothesline with stuff
drying on it even though they seem to have
a washer and dryer already, so the clothesline
must be another throwback to the mini-series
where Pennywise hides behind sheets on the
clothesline to get Laurie-Ann.
Also when Georgie is down in the basement,
he sees a couple of lights which he perceives
as eyes, but we later find out that they kind
of resemble the deadlights that Beverly sees
inside of Pennywise.
When Bill builds the boat for his brother,
Georgie refers to the craft as "it".
Bill corrects him, telling him he should always
call a boat she.
This line goes nicely with what I brought
up earlier about Beverly being the anchor
of the group.
Also, remember Belch's Anthrax shirt I brought
up before?
I noticed that it has text on the back as
well.
It says "follow me or die", which fits in
with Belch's character because he just kind
of blindly follows Henry Bowers out of fear.
It's also clear that he isn't comfortable
with how Henry is cutting Ben's stomach, but
he won't stand up to Henry.
I also have a theory that Belch does die in
this movie, but I'll get back to that in a
bit.
Some people were pointing out that the lady
from the painting creature that Stan is afraid
of resembles Mama, from the 2013 movie Mama,
also directed by Andy Muschietti.
I wouldn't go so far as to say that it's the
same creature, but I can see a slight resemblance.
We see a couple of hero shots of Bill's bike,
which he has named Silver, and in one scene,
while Ben is in the library, Bill and the
others are riding bikes in the street and
he hear the signature phrase, "Hi, ho Silver,
away," which is a reference to the Lone Ranger,
but more importantly, a phrase that Bill imitates
in the book on several occasions when his
speedy bike-riding saves the day.
As Ben is researching in the library, he looks
at a photo from April 3rd, 1908, which is
when the Iron Works explosion was, and Pennywise
can be seen hiding in the photo.
I don't have a still for this, so you'll have
to go see for yourself.
We don't find out a whole lot about Beverly's
father in this movie, but he does wear a shirt
and hat that say "Maintenence".
Originally, Bev's Dad is the school janitor,
so that could explain why he's privy to the
rumors that go around about her.
One of the books in Bev's room is The Frog
Prince, which foreshadows the idea of a kiss
being what brings her back in the end when
Ben’s kiss snaps her out of her trance or
whatever it is that Pennywise has done to
her.
I caught a few more astronomical nods to add
to the ones I listed before.
In Ben's room, he has rather large posters
of the the Earth and the Moon, in addition
to another globe.
A towel on the back of Bev's door appears
to have some space patterns.
There is also a picture of a flying saucer
above Georgie's bed.
And when they first go into the 29 Neibolt
house, Stan has a small icon of the sun on
his shirt.
And while we're bringing up shirts, some of
you wanted me to look into Richie's shirt
that reps: 'Freese's Department Store'.
I guess this was a real life store in the
actual town in Maine that inspired Stephen
King to write Derry.
Beverly has a poster in her room for the punk
band Siouxsie and the Banshees.
Beverly herself is like a frontwoman in a
band of all boys in the losers club.
When the kids go down into the sewer, everything
and everyone that went down the drain over
the course of the film can be found, including
Beverly's hair which is seen dripping out
of a pipe.
After defeating Pennywise, the group shares
a hug, but if you look in the background there
is a light being emitted from the drain that
Pennywise retreated into -- this is IT retaking
it's true form as The Deadlights.
All of the abusive parents in the town are
seen watching the same TV show, which appears
to be a children's show that encourages kids
to go down into the sewers and give themselves
up to Pennywise.
First, Eddie's mom is seen watching it and
we just get a small glimpse.
Next we find Bev's dad watching the program
and hear the line "When you follow your friends
in the sewers, you can be with clowns!"
So that's pretty disturbing.
But then the show is on in front of Henry's
dad who is asleep on the couch near the end.
Pennywise appears and encourages Henry to
kill his father, and then 'kill them all'
in a frenzied chant.
Maybe this show is what brainwashes the adults
-- the reason that they all seem so oblivious
to IT, the reason Bev’s dad can’t see
the blood and the reason Eddie’s Mom won’t
look past the fact that the pills are only
gazebos…
I mean placebos.
This show was also on the TV when I walked
through the Neibolt House Hollywood, so I
got to catch a little bit more of it.
I'll roll that clip for you.
[Clip]
If you want to see that whole walkthrough,
I'll leave a link to my video in the card
right here.
Incidentally, I think Henry does end up "killing
them all," or at least he tries.
When he shows up to ambush the Losers at the
29 Neibolt House just before the film’s
end, he rolls up in Belch's car, the Trans
Am, with considerably more blood on his face
than when we last saw him when he killed his
Dad.
It looks like Belch might be goner, possibly
also Victor.
We'll see if there end up being any deleted
scenes when the Blu-Ray comes out.
Moving on, the mural next to the meat place
that Mike works at is constantly changing.
It starts off innocent enough.
Then after the kids steal from the drug store,
I noticed it depicting something called "The
Brutal Battle", which features a dead person.
Then at some point Pennywise ends up in mural
artwork as well.
Perhaps the biggest thing I'm looking forward
to in the sequel is the possible inclusion
of the flood that overruns Derry.
As a reminder, this happens after the Standpipe
explodes when the remainder of the Losers
Club defeat IT as adults.
I didn't catch this the first time around,
because I always imagined The Standpipe to
be an actual pipe that ruptures, but as it
turns out it's actually a full on building
and there are a lot of references to it.
Upon first meeting Ben, he's carrying a school
project which is a model of The Standpipe.
He ends up dropping it, causing it to pop
off the ground, just like it presumably will
in the next movie.
The postcard he buys for Beverly contains
a picture of The Standpipe.
When he first exits the library he cuts through
Memorial Park, where The Standpipe is supposed
to be located.
It’s also somewhat near Beverly's apartment.
A shot of the Standpipe ends up being used
as a transition before a scene taking place
at her home.
And finally, I think that the final battle
with Pennywise at the end of the movie is
supposed to be located inside The Standpipe.
When they look up at the giant tower of floating
kids, the shape of the structure that they’re
in looks to be the same shape as the outside
of The Standpipe, and if it is going to burst,
it would make sense that the pressure would
start building from directly below.
And last, but maybe most importantly of all,
Richie's T-shirt in the final scene is a Bike
and Cycle Shop graphic tee.
Aside from that being the store that Bill
originally buys his bike, Silver, from in
the book, I was able to make one other connection.
The only other Cycling shirt I noticed in
the movie was Georgie's in the very opening
scene, before he even puts on the raincoat.
Maybe the word "cycle", takes on a second
meaning here.
Derry is constantly stuck in a "cycle" of
Pennywise re-emerging every 27 years.
And this time that cycle begins with the murder
of Georgie and effectively ends when Richie
has the bravery to stand up and attack Pennywise.
But like all cycles, the events that make
it up, the spokes of the metaphorical wheel,
will come around again in Chapter 2.
I know this video was a little on the long
side, hopefully you found it to be a longy
but a goody.
Just like my...
Last episode of Al Dente Creepypasta, which
you can check out right here.
Or if you're interested in more Things You
Missed, have a look at this playlist.
I've got myself a little cycle of my own going
on right now, it's the cycle of new horrors
every Wednesday and Saturday in October, so
remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that death-bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.